huge movie weekend ladies and gentlemen
we got to talk about that curious who
else saw Dumbo
seriously one guy saw Dumbo did anybody
see any other movie oh there's been the
Avengers what I mean did it go to any
movie other than the Avengers I have no
idea yeah I I didn't get to see I didn't
get to see the Avengers movie yes did
not go I was I was in the hospital
passing an infinity stone also three
hours and two minutes by the way I
didn't make any money off of it but
beautiful
Oh beautiful yeah yeah wait it's doing
really well on Rotten Tomatoes money I
was gonna go I was gonna go with my kids
and my son said you can't go you can't
go unless you've seen all of the other
Marvel movies all of the 38 other movies
you know and I haven't I haven't seen
them all I may not be caught up on the
Avengers but ladies an gentlemen I am a
hundred percent caught up on the Shahs
of Sunset that's just a reference I
enjoy it's not even a show I know this
is true in China in China where the
movie that's one of the reasons the
movies such a success it did massive
business in China in China an Avengers
fan cried so hard during the movie he
was hospitalized
that's true yeah doctors ordered him to
get some rest
and never watch the notebook that's what
they told marvel did announce that
endgame is the fourth and final final
Avengers movie it's the last one yeah
Marvel's exact words were we're sick of
money
[Applause]